NO SIGNS IT WILL BE COMING
ANYTIME SOON.
>> MARK MEREDITH LIVE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THANK YOU.
LET’S BRING IN THE DIRECTOR OF
PRESS COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW THIS EVENT AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE WAS NOT PUT ON BY
THE CAMPAIGN, BUT IS THIS
PERHAPS A TASTE OF WHAT FUTURE
RALLIES MIGHT LOOK LIKE MINUS
THE FIREWORKS?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS EXCITED TO
BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND GIVE WHAT
WILL BE AN ICONIC ADDRESS IN
FRONT OF MOUNT RUSHMORE.
HE IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CELEBRATE AMERICA’S HISTORY IN
FRONT OF MOUNT RUSHMORE.
THOSE WHO STOOD UP IN THE FACE
OF TYRANNY TO ESTABLISH THE
GREATEST NATION THE WORLD HAS
EVER KNOWN, HONOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY WHO SERVED A NN DAY OUT
TO PROTECT AND BRING FREEDOM
ACROSS THE WORLD AND PROTECT IT
HERE AT HOME AND HE WILL TALK
ABOUT THE HIGH HONOR AND
DISTINCTION WE ALL HAVE AS
AMERICANS AND CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT’S GOING TO BE A BEAUTIFUL
SPEECH AT ONE OF AMERICA’S MOST
ICONIC LOCATIONS.
>> WE JUST HEARD JONATHAN HUNT
REPORT, THIS EVENT COMES WITH
ITS FAIR SHARE OF CRITICISM.
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS NOT GOING
TO BE ENFORCED.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS, THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRE, AND THESE
NATIVE AMERICAN GROUPS WHO ARE
PLANNING TO PROTEST BECAUSE THEY
ARE SAYING THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A
PHOTO OP AT ONE OF THEIR MOST
SACRED SITES.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT
CRITICISM?
>> OF THE GOVERNOR HAS CLEARLY
BEEN WORKING TO ESTABLISH
PROTOCOLS FOR SAFETY AND WE
ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO MAY BE IN A
HIGHER RISK GROUP TO BE ABLE TO
ENJOY THE FESTIVITIES SAFELY AT
HOME AS WELL.
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE A PART OF
THIS THEY ARE AND AWAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FIREWORKS
SPECIFICALLY, NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN SAFELY,
THAT THESE FIREWORKS CAN HAPPEN
SAFELY.
IN PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
STAND IN FRONT OF A NATIONAL
MONUMENT AND GIVE A SPEECH TO
OUR NATION.
WILL BE BEAUTIFUL AND PATRIOTIC
AND IT WILL HONOR THE GREATNESS
OF THIS NATION, ALL OF IT.
>> Kristin: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THE BIG JOBS REPORT YESTERDAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SOUNDING VERY
PLEASED WITH IT BUT HIS OPPONENT
JOE BIDEN IS ESSENTIALLY
ACCUSING HIM OF SPIKING THE
FOOTBALL AT THE 50-YARD LINE.
HE SAID ON TWITTER, LET ME BE
CLEAR, THERE IS NO VICTORY TO BE
CELEBRATED WHEN WE ARE STILL
DOWN NEARLY 15 MILLION JOBS IN
THE PANDEMIC IS GETTING WORSE,
NOT BETTER.
DOES HE HAVE A POINT?
11.1% UNEMPLOYMENT IS STILL VERY
HIGH.
>> DESPITE DEMOCRATS AND
JOE BIDEN’S BEST EFFORTS TO ROOT
AGAINST THE COMEBACK, THE WORK
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID TO PROTECT
AMERICAN WORKERS AND JOBS IS
CLEARLY PAYING OFF.
WE’VE HAD ALMOST SEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION JOBS CREATED IN TWO
MONTHS.
4.8 MILLION JOBS IN THE MONTH
OF JUNE ALONE AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THOSE NUMBERS, 2.8 MILLION OF
THOSE JOBS WENT TO WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
OVER 350,000 WENT TO
MANUFACTURING.
THERE’S PLENTY TO CELEBRATE BUT
THE MEDIA, THE TALKING HEADS WHO
WANT TO ROOT AGAINST THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY THINK
AMERICAN FAILURE IS THERE
SUCCESS AS SEEN ANYTHING ABOUT
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE,
THEY KNOW THEY ARE ON THE WRONG
PATH.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DELIVERED AMERICAN GREATNESS AND
HE’S DOING IT AGAIN.
HE HAS SHOWN HIS LEADERSHIP WILL
BRING THIS COUNTRY BACK.
JOE BIDEN SHOULD SEE WHAT’S
HAPPENING BECAUSE THERE IS
PLENTY TO CELEBRATE IN THE
RECENT JOBS NUMBERS.
>> I HOPE THE NEXT JOBS REPORT
IS JUST AS GOOD AS THE LAST ONE
BECAUSE THAT SURVEY WAS TAKEN IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE PREVIOUS MONTH
BEFORE A LOT OF THESE STATES HAD
TO PAUSE THEIR REOPENING PLANS
SO DEFINITELY SOME CONCERNING
TRENDS THE JOB SUPPORT WAS
PRETTY GOOD, SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS SO PLEASED ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON